Have you seen that girl...
...who's been fishing around in our trash?
If you see her, can you help her?
Yeah I promise.
Hey, have you seen my...
Henry.
What?
Promise me now.
I promise.
Hey!
Don't you know no better than to be sneaking up on people?
What's with all of the junk?
I'm building something.
Oh yeah?
I'm an architect you know, maybe I could...
You're not one of them pervs who likes to touch little girls, are you?
You torched my shed!
That was an accident.
Do you have any idea how long it took me to...
What? Build a raft?
I have your plans right here.
I've got a ton of ideas.
I really think I'm supposed to do this, to help you.
Let's get one thing clear:...
...I'm doing it 'cause I got no choice.
And if you mess with my stuff, I'll beat your ass.
I'm helping her.
Helping her with what?
We're building a raft.
This is madness.
No, it's not!
And Penny would have loved this.
Those are pontoons.
Should we just wait 'til the tide washes them in?
What was she like?
She was kind of wild.
Like a hurricane?
We ain't lost our minds, we just lost our way a little bit.